l'actualité internationale est cette
fois c'est certain laurent désiré kabila
est mort il aurait succombé à ses
blessures la nuit dernière à harare au
zimbabwe ou ont tenté de le soigner
il sera enterré mardi prochain à
kinshasa mais déjà son fils a pris les
rênes de la république démocratique du
congo sans élection jean marc pitte le
meurtrier de laurent désiré kabila était
apparemment l'un des membres de sa garde
présidentielle
c'est au coeur du palais de marbre que
l'homme aurait agi là où seuls les
gardes du corps du président sont
autorisés à porter une arme
il aurait touché par cinq fois sa cible
avant d'être lui-même abattu par l'un de
ses collègues un proche du président
aurait peu de temps après tenté de
quitter le pays à bord d'un avion de la
sabena
ils auraient été interceptés et arrêtés
d'abord transporté dans une clinique de
kinshasa laurent désiré kabila aurait
ensuite été évacué vers harare la
capitale du zimbabwe
par mesure de sécurité difficile
d'établir exactement le moment de son
décès toujours est il que les autorités
de la république démocratique du congo
ont préféré retarder durant de longues
heures
l'annoncé de sa mort pour se donner le
temps de sécuriser le pays et de
préparer la succession du président
autoproclamé
réunis en conseil extraordinaire les
ministres ont confié hier à joseph
kabila la succession de son père le
général major de 31 ans cumule ainsi la
responsabilité du gouvernement et le
commandement de l'armée
un héritage déjà contestée par l'un des
chefs de l'opposition depuis bruxelles
etienne tshisekedi a confié son espoir
de voir la mort du dictateur ouvrir un
processus démocratique auquel il compte
participer
je veux présenter à la présidence de la
république ça c'est évident et j'ai nié
que sans fausse modestie
le peuple congolais me fait confiance et
j'ai joué le rôle en fonction de la
confiance que le peuple me fais
ce soir alors que la nouvelle de la mort
de kabila est désormais une certitude
dans le monde entier
aucune annonce officielle n'a encore été
faite à la radio ou à la télévision
congolaise
une annonce qui devrait intervenir à 20h
heure française